whew that's an attractive thumbnail am I
right boys
the protagonist of the movie is a high
school student named yoshiro kemogawa he
spends most of his days aimlessly and is
pretty average at studies as far as
popularity is concerned yoshiro is
ignored by almost all the girls in his
school as they believe he is a dork but
one day Everything Changes yoshiro
proceeds to climax fantasizing about
different girls however he has a hard
time choosing one particular girl as
yoshiro is obsessed about finding the
girl of his Destiny he had already met
that girl when they were inside their
mother's wombs in a hospital what what
is happening right now they communicated
with each other telepathically and
promised to meet soon using a special
jingle which is their secret code now
images of his soulmate come into his
mind in fragments yoshiro sees her
waving at him and the two kiss on their
tiptoes back in the present as yoshiro
thinks of her and is about to climax to
the thought of that sweet fetus a rare
Cosmic phenomenon takes place in outer
space and a shaft of light shines on him
he is startled but doesn't think much of
it elsewhere Yoshi Rose classmate miyuko
harano is also dreaming about having
coitus hence she too is hit by the
strange light the next morning when
yoshiro sits down for breakfast with his
mother and her boyfriend he is strangely
able to hear their internal thoughts
yoshiro is horrified by the lewd and
lascivious thoughts of his mother and
her boyfriend so he leaves breakfast and
heads out for school still puzzled about
everything at school he is again
bombarded by everyone's internal
thoughts he telepathically hears his
teacher admit to herself that she wants
to be the hottest female in school while
she disciplines female students for
wearing short skirts yoshiro is soon
joined by his best friend and the two
boys watching Wonder as a beautiful girl
named Psy arrives there Psy is a new
student and yoshiro is instantly Smitten
by her beauty suddenly a gust of wind
lifts size skirt revealing her
undergarments this gives yoshiro and his
male friend an instant and very visible
hard on miyuko watches it transpire from
nearby and decides to embarrass the two
boys this obviously enrages yoshiro so
he starts to be rating her in his mind
to his astonishment he realizes that
miyuko can also read people's minds when
she counters his remark telepathically
in class the teacher introduces Psy to
everyone yoshiro again fawns over her
and he starts to wonder if Psy is the
girl of his Destiny the scene then cuts
to Tokyo University Professor Asami and
his assistant misakiyama discussing the
rumors about psychic activity in the
town it turns out Professor Asami has
been researching extra sensory
perception or ESP for a while now
because of which he had become an object
of ridicule among his colleagues
elsewhere after school a confused
yoshiro buys a book about ESP which
includes topics like telepathy
telekinesis teleportation and
Clairvoyance later on his way home
yoshiro stops by to meet his perverted
older male friend named Teru Teru owns a
restaurant and spends his free time
thinking about coitus that's so weird no
one does that he introduces yoshiro to
adult toys the sus and also Reveals His
telekinetic power using which he can
lift objects without physically touching
them however strangely teru's power is
only limited to sexual objects imagine
you get a superpower but all it does is
levitate butt plugs the next day yoshiro
decides to approach Psy but on his way
he reads a fellow student inomoto's mind
and learns that he is planning to get
naked in front of Psy and other girls
yoshiro tries to stop him but shockingly
inomoto has the ability to teleport from
one place to another he goes directly
inside the girl's locker room and
exposes himself but his plan fails
terribly just then Professor Asami and
misakiyama confront the new psychics and
gather them at his place during the
operation it's revealed that misakiyama
also has a strange psychic power she has
the power of precognition which allows
her to foresee the future of anyone who
looks at her bra the new psychics
include yoshiro Teru inomoto miyuko and
another creepy student named yabe it's
revealed that yabe is Clairvoyant which
gives him the ability to see through
objects soon professor mommy introduces
himself and explains that he has been
researching ESP for a while now he also
reveals that yoshiro and the others got
their powers because of a cosmic
phenomenon it turns out they are not the
first ones to acquire ESP 200 years ago
in Duluth Minnesota there was another
psychic Awakening cosmic rays hit the
city when the planets were aligned in a
particular way and imparted these powers
on some people this time similar cosmic
rays hit Japan yoshiro and others got
the ESP because they fit a certain
criteria first they are virgins they had
never had kotis second when the Rays hit
town they were all aroused thirdly they
noticed their power Asami claims that he
and his research team have been trying
to harness this energy from space for
good he also reveals that the psychics
from the American town were killed by
other evil psychics this means that
there are some other psychics in this
town too and they might abuse their
powers Asami tells the group that they
must protect their town from duluth's
fate just then Psy appears from the
washroom and it's revealed that she is
Professor asami's daughter the movie
then cuts to the home of a fairy Skipper
named Akiko kamiya who has also acquired
psychic powers she has recently come out
as a lesbian and is on a mission to find
herself a girlfriend however because
everyone ignores her she has started
misusing her power to freeze other girls
and take advantage of them that is not
chill later that night someone dumps
tens and won hundreds of adult dolls in
yoshiro's high school Professor Asami
misakiyama and some detectives quickly
arrive at the scene upon close
inspection Asami learns that someone has
laced the dolls with an aphrodisiac he
collects a sample of the drug and
instructs misakiyama to hide the news
from yoshiro and others to keep them
from panicking the next day a new
teacher joins yoshiro's school she is a
Japanese-American woman named Mia
palnareth Miss palmeraf is very sex
positive and in her first interaction
with the students she delivers a
passionate speech she says that Earth is
in a crisis and people have lost hope
hence everyone should embrace love and
be erotic hope Miss palmerath is
passionate about going to jail too later
Paul norath catches yoshiro staring at
Psy so she approaches him and places her
hand over his head lo and behold she
reads yoshiro's memory and claims that
she is the girl of his Destiny before
walking away with her two scantily clad
female assistants it turns out palmerath
is a psychic too meanwhile after
examining the sample from the adult doll
Professor Asami concludes that the
substance is not from Earth he fears
that it could be part of the evil
psychics plan in the next scene we are
taken to the psychic akika's house where
a large group of high school girls
emerge seemingly under some spell they
get on akiko's Fairy before heading off
somewhere later Akiko is seen standing
by the river and blowing some mysterious
powder over the entire town from her
mouth the next day taru accompanies
yoshiro and miyuko to school after
hearing about Miss palmerath and her
erotic nature to their surprise they
witnessed that all the students are
dressed scantily soon Miss Palmer F
walks up to the trio and using her
ability she figures out that miyuko and
Teru too have psychic powers not only
the high schoolers but the entire town
is seemingly under some spell and they
are walking around in their
undergarments next a group of female
cosplayers take several innocent
civilians hostage at City Hall they
threaten the city's mayor to fulfill
their several demands or else they will
hurt the hostages some of their demands
are love hotels should become free
nudist beaches should be legalized the
adult industry should be promoted and so
on soon Professor Asami and that psychic
pedo Miss palmerath arrive at the scene
and the latter demands to speak with the
leader of the protesters just then Akiko
steps ahead and reveals that she is
behind all of this she also reveals that
she has psychic powers and goes on a
rant about greedy humans then she orders
her girls to attack Asami and the others
suddenly a mysterious woman appears and
casts a spell on akiko's Army instantly
turning them into lifeless adult dolls
Akiko is taken aback and she immediately
flees the scene as everyone tries to
make sense of what just happened the
mysterious woman also disappears without
introducing herself after school while
PSY and her friends walk past akiko's
house unaware about the lurking danger
Psy's friends are spooked by the vibe of
the house and they run away but Akiko
manages to kidnap Sai later she also
makes miyuko her victim in no time the
town spirals out of control everyone has
suddenly become obsessed with coitus and
they constantly have evil thoughts
seeing all women in town wearing bikinis
gives every male except for tarou a
constant hard-on unable to get it up he
is embarrassed but miss polnerv Comforts
him saying that a man's value isn't just
in his manhood it's also in his wallet
next yoshiro gets a call from Psy and
she asks him to meet in a garden just
like his dream yoshiro watches Psy run
up to him with her long beautiful legs
singing the jingle and waving her hands
she thanks him for helping her father
with his ESP research before leaning in
for a kiss on her tiptoes and asking him
for intercourse yoshiro is taken aback
as he didn't imagine Psy to be so
forward suddenly the mysterious woman
from earlier appears and she turns Psy
into an adult doll much to yoshiro's
horror Professor Asami and the others
arrive at the scene and the woman
introduces herself as Julie Babcock a
psychic from Duluth she reveals that
some psychics survived the Duluth
Massacre and they went into hiding Julie
is a descendant of those psychics she
has come all the way to Japan to prevent
another tragedy like that of her home
City meanwhile a detective tracks down
akiko's house and learns that she has
been kidnapping girls from her
neighborhood she reports it to Professor
Asami and the latter quickly comes up
with a plan he sends yoshiro disguised
as a girl to lure the kidnapper towards
him while the others watch from hiding
unfortunately Akiko spots Miss akiyama
behind a pole and proceeds to hypnotize
her but before she can do so the psychic
lady reads her future by flashing her
bra Akiko immediately runs away and
misakiyama reveals that she is headed
towards the city hall wasting no time
Professor Asami and his group head for
the city hall and there they come across
all the kidnapped girls in a passed out
State they also find multiple girls
claiming to be the real sigh in the
hallway the creepy psychic yabe uses his
Clairvoyance to reveal that they are all
clones after a while Akiko finally
appears with her Army of scantily
dressed girls but Julie immediately
turned some of them into dolls Furious
Akiko sends more girls to attack yoshiro
and the others before running away as
the group deals with the army of girls
Miss polnerv grabs yoshiro and escorts
him to safety yoshiro gullibly follows
her but she takes him to the stage and
traps him in an enclosure Miss palmerath
then opens the curtains revealing three
life-size cutouts of pregnant women it
turns out that she has held yoshiro
captive inside the womb of one of the
cutouts whoever directed this movie has
so much crap to work out next it's
revealed that PSY and miyuko have been
held captive in the womb of the other
two cutouts yoshiro discovers this and
speaks to the girls who are distraught
about their situation to calm herself
down miyuko starts singing this special
jingle taken aback yoshiro finally
realizes that the girl of his Destiny is
none other than miyuko he tells her that
it's him she promised to meet after
taking birth with this the two Cry tears
of joy and yoshiro finally sees the face
of miyuko in the dream sequence running
up to him with long legs however before
they could kiss miss palmerath
interrupts causing him to snap out of
his dream she then claims that she
taught that song to miyuko much to
yoshiro's astonishment meanwhile
Professor Asami and his group turn
akiko's Army into dolls with the help of
Julie with nowhere to go Akiko finally
accepts defeat but warns them that her
master Miss palmerath will teach them a
lesson Julie then purifies her soul and
it's revealed that Akiko was only a
puppet acting under Miss Palmer F's
spell with this information Professor
Asami finally figures out that the
cunning Polner F has the ability to
control people's memories she deletes
rewrites transplants memories and even
manipulates them to suit her needs
meanwhile Miss polnerv orders her Hench
women to escort SEI and miyuko away as
she tries to get close to yoshiro
Professor Asami and others arrive when
taru questions her motives miss
palmeroff asserts that she is doing all
this to wipe out Humanity from Earth she
hates humans because they violate nature
and are greedy only God's chosen will
remain Miss palmerath then claims that
yoshiro is the chosen one and expresses
her love for him she also reveals that
she can't control his memory because of
her feelings for him just then Julie
interrupts Her speech and tries to
purify her soul but to her astonishment
polnerv has no evil intentions and in
the blink of an eye she overpowers Julie
and knocks her out the other psychics
attack Miss polnerv but she easily
defeats them into races their memory she
then turns to yoshiro and asks him to
come with her threatening to kill him
otherwise at first the naive Schoolboy
refuses but when Miss palmeroff mentions
that the Earth's fate depends on him he
agrees following this she takes him to a
nursery where she has turned Sai miyuko
and herself into children polnerv says
that she wants to be a child again
because they are pure Souls unlike
adults however yoshiro refuses to become
a child and insists he'd rather Climax
and have coitus as an adult you tell him
yoshiro his erotic speech soon discussed
sponerath as she wants to be the girl of
his Destiny not a play thing hence she
yells in agony and decides to leave for
good after Paul norath leaves the town
returns back to normal and everyone
thanks yoshiro for making it happen he
is no less than an Avenger to them move
over Scott Lang Ant-Man meet hot Wang
put your hands in your pants man the
next day when yoshiro reaches school he
finds all the girls singing his favorite
jingle confused he wonders how everyone
knows about it the movie ends as a
narration reveals that yoshiro's mother
actually sat next to numerous pregnant
women in a tram after she exited the
hospital from her womb yoshiro
telepathically communicated with all the
unborn girls present there hence all of
them are his soul mates now subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching